جاء بعد 48 ساعه فقط برا
[موسيقى]
محكمه اللاجئين الفلسطينيين وانهاء عمل
وكاله
الاونروا نشارك اليوم كمؤسسات فلسطينيه
وقوى وفعاليات شعبيه امام مكتب النوره في
لبنان لنؤكد على تمسكنا بهذه الوكاله
الامميه والتي هي معنيه بتقديم المساعدات
والبرامج الاغاثه والتشغيليه
وان هذه الوكاله
ميه باللاجئين حتى تطبيق حق
العوده هذا القرار يؤثر على 6 ملايين لاجئ
فلسطيني يعيشون في غزه والضفه والاردن
وسوريا ولبنان وينقل عبء الخدمات التي
يحصل عليها هؤلاء اللاجئين من الانروا
ينقلها الى الحكومات المستضيفه وال
المجتمعات المستضيفه وهذا يؤدي الى ازمات
سياسيه واقتصاديه واجتماعيه
[موسيقى]
كبيره يعني كمان دعم الان عم تغص 200000
200 ال
شخص غير الموت ينف تحت
الخي تحت القص
المنط الولايات المتحده الامريكيه طبعا
امت
هؤلاء